welcome everyone to today's event
promising RSV vaccines on the horizon
this event is organized by Science
magazine in collaboration with the Texas
Science Festival at the University of
Texas at Austin and I'm Megan Fallon
director of The Press package at the
science family of journals
this is a very timely discussion on RSV
or respiratory synthesial virus RSB as
many of you know is a seasonal illness
that can be deadly for babies and
elderly people and unfortunately RSV
cases surged this past winter
overwhelming hospitals all over the
country
though there's been no vaccine available
for RSV for decades scientists did try
one out in the 60s but it didn't work
and we'll talk about that today now here
in 2023 we're in a very different Place
several promising RSV vaccine candidates
that work in a whole new way compared to
past candidates could be available very
soon in fact yesterday one RSV vaccine
candid for the elderly was the subject
of review by an FDA independent advisory
committee these advisors recommended
that the FDA approved this vaccine today
they're weighing in on a second RSV
vaccine from another pharmaceutical
company also for the elderly and we'll
have updates there as soon as an hour
from now potentially
our guests today including three
scientists and one journalists are the
perfect people to be talking to us about
the history behind these vaccines
development and the science it took to
get us to where we are today
before I introduce them I want to invite
viewers to post your questions in the
chat I'd also encourage you to let us
know where you're listening from we'd
love to hear where people are joining us
from around the world I'm going to the
discussion today should last about 30
minutes I have several questions for our
speakers but I also look forward to
taking yours in the audience
and now we will get right to our
speakers
so our first guest is Barney Graham he's
a senior advisor for Global Health
Equity at Morehouse School of Medicine
in Atlanta Georgia he spent 20 years as
an investigator at the National
Institute of allergy and infectious
diseases and retired as deputy director
of the vaccine Research Center there
he's received multiple Awards in his
career including for his work on
vaccines against covid-19 and RSV
hi Barney it's really exciting to talk
to you this week
it's nice to see everyone nice to be
here
Jason MccLellan works at the University
of Texas at Austin where the Texas
Science Festival is happening now his
lab is focused on understanding and
visualizing how hosts and pathogens
interact and he and his team use this
information to develop vaccines and
immunotherapies McClellan developed
technology that features in most current
covid-19 vaccines as well as the new
vaccines against RSV hey Jason it's good
to be with you on Festival week hey
Megan thanks for having me
Nan Chen is a recently retired staff
scientist at the vaccine Research Center
where she worked with Barney and other
colleagues she joined the vaccine
Research Center in 2002. today we're
going to hear about work she did
including involving International
collaboration to support RSV vaccine
development Hi man I can't wait to hear
your insights Hi Megan thank you I'm
looking forward to talk to you
thank you hi everyone
and our last speaker is Gregory zuckerin
a special writer at the Wall Street
Journal where he's worked for nearly
three decades he's also the author of
multiple best-selling books his latest a
shot to save the world the inside story
of the Life or Death Race for a covid-19
vaccine is reportedly informing an
upcoming HBO documentary it does a
tremendous job explaining the
Technologies behind vaccine development
and the heroes including those on this
panel involved in the process as related
to covet 19. hi Greg how are you hey
everybody nice to see everyone
and I'd like to start with Greg as we
kick off our discussion today and again
people watching please feel free to post
your questions we'd really like to hear
your questions about the science and the
technology involved in developing these
vaccines and the history of that work
and broader questions too but so Greg
let's start big picture here your book
about the development of the covid-19
vaccines talks about how scientists
turned years of underappreciated work
into life-saving vaccines at incredible
speed speed we'd never seen before they
did this so quickly in part because they
were able to take advantage of insights
from RSV vaccine development so to give
our viewers a sense of how these two
major efforts aligned and diverged now
what are the parallels in the way the
covid and RSV vaccines were developed
what are the major differences
sure
um I'm going to answer that question as
an outsider I'm a journalist I write
about the scientists the researchers and
the executives and what struck me
writing my book is I kept hearing about
the work done with RSV I kept hearing
about worked on with HIV and I don't
think people are appreciative of the
persistence and the resilience and uh
the patience that's required for some of
these breakthroughs including RSV and
we're going to hear a few minutes in a
few minutes from from Barney and from
Jason and they're Heroes and I think
people need to appreciate
um the the level of patience and
persistence that's required and that's
in common for both and for all
breakthroughs and also the importance of
just basic science basic research that
goes on in labs around the country and
around the world for years people
persisting and deep in these labs and
um I come from a world where we want
results we want to produce some
something right away we want to see it
right away if not immediately then the
next day and I really have so much
newfound respect for these researchers
who spend years maybe even decades as
we're going to hear in a few minutes uh
on RSV before they get their
breakthroughs and the results and we
still need that in more than ever and we
are potentially on the on the cusp of a
remarkable breakthrough of the RSV where
maybe the lives that will be saved that
will be helped might even be more so
than the cobit vaccines and not enough I
think Acclaim has accrued to these
researchers so I'm eager to hear about
them myself but there are a lot of
similarities in that persistence and in
the importance of just basic science and
it's a good reminder for us all of the
importance of both
yeah thanks Greg I feel so lucky to have
these researchers on with us the way
they've persisted the history they have
here uh let's let's go to Barney on that
note Barney your history with RSV is
long as as Greg alluded to it's a great
story of how basic research puts us in a
position to make usable products could
you tell us how you got interested in
studying RSV
well all my work in virology really
stemmed from
being in training during the Advent of
the HIV
pandemic so seeing one of the first
patients in Tennessee with HIV in 1982
led me to to want to do biology and
most virology at that time in laboratory
work at least is done in the pediatric
department so when I went to Peter
Wright and Kathy Edwards and David
carzon at Vanderbilt
in their Pediatric Group
they allowed me to come in as an
internist and and start work on a
respiratory virus
respiratories and social works
okay and and so so the audience can know
a little bit about the history of
vaccines for Respiratory Sensational
virus there was a trial of an RSV
vaccine candidate in the 60s as I
alluded to in my opening remarks but it
led to a a a not an ideal outcome can
you tell us a little bit about what
happened and and why Barney
yes
I got into RSV research to study safety
to study vaccine safety and
and safety is really the first step it's
you know Do no harm is the one of the
anthems of medical scientists and
in
1960s shortly after Salk had had such
success with the polio vaccine by just
simply inactivating the virus and using
that as the vaccine
when RSV was discovered in 1956 similar
steps were taken and by
1965 or so
a whole inactivated virus vaccine was
tested in infants and in the youngest
cohort of infants
in a relatively small trial 31 infants
received the vaccine
and 20 of them were infected during that
next winter season and 16 of them out of
20 80 percent had to be hospitalized and
two died
and that was a vaccine enhanced disease
and I
I spent the first 20 years of my career
studying the basis and the pathogenesis
and the Immunology of
the vaccine-enhanced disease hoping to
get to a place where we could safely
develop RSV mixes
I'm sitting here thank
you I think very very concerning results
and and so after that first failure in
the 1960s what happened to the the pace
of vaccine development for RSV and how
how did things look who was involved
for those decades
well
that could have stopped RSV vaccine
development for a few decades and then
when work was restarted it was focused
in part on the elderly
because what was known is that once
you've been infected with RSV or once
you've gotten a live virus vaccine with
RSV that That vaccine enhanced disease
was no longer an issue
it was something that happened in babies
if they got that kind of vaccine on
their very first exposure to the virus
so work had started again on an adult
and by the mid 90s and in children using
live attenuated vaccine approaches
and but it didn't go very far and and so
in addition to vaccine safety you also
have to design a vaccine that that can
work that can actually stimulate
sufficient immunity to to be protective
and so
safeties first efficacy development is
is next and
it took us a few years to get to that
and we did a lot of work with vaccines
that elicited t-cell-based immunity and
and then eventually
around 2008 or nine when Jason came to
the BRC we and I and he was in Peter
quang's life Lab at the time we started
working on a new approach to RSV
focused on generating better antibody
responses
that's a great segue thank you Barney I
want to go now to
um to 2013 a few years after
the time that Jason came to the VRC so
that year Barney Jason and Mann
published a paper in science
highlighting research that focused on
this the new design that Barney alluded
to research that would lay the
groundwork for creating an RSV the RSV
vaccines in clinical trials today we'll
post a link to that 2013 science paper
in in the comments but the paper showed
that they developed a candidate that led
to much higher protective responses than
other leading RSV vaccine candidates
they did so using new insights into the
structure of What's called the viruses F
protein which the virus uses to dock to
cells normally the F protein flips back
and forth changing shapes after it
attaches to a cell but this group
figured out how to freeze the protein
into the shape that it takes before it
fuses that's what's called its
pre-fusion form and very important for
vaccine development they showed that a
vaccine against rf's V would be but it
would have a greater chance of success
in triggering strong antibodies if it
was directed at this pre-fusion form of
the F protein
but figuring out the pre-fusion
structure of the F protein was not easy
Jason this is this is your world can you
explain a little bit about what it took
to do this
yeah so the rsvf protein it's similar to
the coronavirus Spike there are Fusion
proteins they as you mentioned start off
in an initial prefusion state
fold into a post-fusion state and that
helps fuse the viral membrane with the
Hostile membrane that initial state is
unstable so the metastable but that's
the form we want to use as a vaccine
antigen we want to train our immune
systems to recognize this this initial
form and
so one of the tricks then is how do you
stabilize it in this unstable form and
we want to do that with structural
biology be able to determine high
resolution three-dimensional atomic
structures of this protein so that way
we can then rationally engineer in
substitutions to help block the protein
but first we had to get the structure
and to do that we were able to take
advantage and identify antibodies that
could bind to the unstable form and lock
it and prevent it from switching
conformations and so the first structure
we obtained was an antibody bound
complex of the prefusion of protein
thanks Jason yeah and and now I'd like
to talk a little bit to man man you
traveled to China to support this work
and and you were looking for the
antibodies that Jason alluded to that
would bind to
um pre-fusion f can you explain how many
antibodies you tested there and how long
it took to find those that had really
strong protective responses but only
bound to pre-fusion F and not post
Fusion f
sure
first of all I want to talk briefly
about Jose malaro who is really
important part of this story who was a
virologist at a national Center for
psychobiology in Spain
Jose malaros group find the human Serum
with high title of neutralizing antibody
retained the most of neutralization
activity after a post F of trophy
which is suggested the potent
neutralizing antibody was from
pre-fusion f
and the prefusion F would be better
immunity than Constitution f
in 2011 we started working on solving
the pre-fusion of structure because
Jose's work
we knew we need a specific antibody to
bend the pre-fusion F and lock it in
pre-fusion conformation for
crystallization because I suggestion
talked the pre-fusion f is meant stable
it's hard to gain the increase at the
Crystal of prefix in F we decided to
collaborate with Professor Linda at
xiamen University China for making the
antibody because his group had the
expertise on making antibody by
hypoderma technology
in 2011 I made a trip to xiamen
University in Professor xiao's labor
working on this project
we isolated one prefusion antibody
and which was screwing out from the over
10 000 colognes we named the the
antibody 5c4
then we use 5c4 for the crystallization
prefusion of protein
thanks man so you talked about screening
thousands of clones what criteria did
you use to isolate the specific
pre-fusion F antibody that you
ultimately kind of found and landed on
is important to continue to study
yeah we cite a tool criteria first the
antibody could neutralizing R3 but it
should not bind to post Fusion life but
use this criteria with swing out the
free vision of antibody
thank you man okay so so back to today
so now we are um and in an important
time here several major pharmacutical
companies pharmaceutical companies have
used the technique you all have
described to develop vaccines that have
proved their worth in clinical trials
and one design is is a vaccine for
people over 60 another is for pregnant
women who could pass antibodies or pass
immunity to their babies there's also a
monoclonal antibody a one-time injection
that's being evaluated that would be for
for infants this is tremendous progress
and we've also seen as I mentioned in my
opening remarks the FDA advisory
committee is weighing in this week with
votes of approval at least yesterday
we're waiting to see what will happen in
the second vote today but based on the
news yesterday and on on the vaccine for
for the elderly to start Barney to come
back to you what do you think about when
we could expect the vaccine for the
elderly for example to be approved and
available what what might be a possible
timeline
well most of these products have
receive breakthrough status and Rapid
review
Privileges and so once the biologics
license application is submitted to the
FDA they have six months to give them
back an answer and so some of these
products like the two products being
that had been tested in the elderly
are under the review today of the verpa
committee the vaccines related
[Music]
biologics through advisory committee and
and
um so they'll be voting they'll be
looking at both efficacy and side
effects from these vaccines and then the
FDA will have to make a decision
within the next few weeks or months so
decisions will be made about all these
products by the next winter season
okay
I want to pause for a moment I'm sure
that that's very interesting for the
audience audience if you have questions
please do enter them in the chat we'll
be happy to raise your questions to our
speakers
we've talked a lot about the vaccines
but what about the monoclonal antibody
what's its status in review and when
might we ex and could you explain a
little bit about who it's intended for
this this is for
babies before they would be become ill
is is that correct Jason maybe we could
go to you for this question
I love Barney handle the question about
the the review in different stages but
in terms of how the antibody Works uh so
it's a it's an antibody we actually used
it's a modified form of the antibody we
use to solve the the original structure
uh back then it was called d25 and it
binds the Apex straight down uh almost
at the top of the RSV fusion protein and
it binds to regions of the protein that
need to refold and undergo a
conformational change to adopt the
post-fusion state so by binding really
just locks the protein now the virus
can't enter cells that's the type of
antibody uh one of them that we're sort
of hoping the the vaccines will elicit
that's why we want to use the pre-fusion
stabilized form of the F protein so that
way when injected you can elicit this
type of antibody and so for you can do
active vaccination where you inject a
viral protein or pathogen pathogen
pathogenic protein and try to I have the
body elicit those antibodies or you can
do passive immunization and just
directly inject the purified antibody
and so that's what this is being
developed for for perhaps high risk
infants might be two maybe they're too
young to vaccinate directly so you can
inject them with the antibody and
perhaps protect them for the first six
months of life or the first RSV season
as a parent with an infant that's that's
very exciting news and um what about the
review status for that one Barney the
monoclonal antibody nurse nurse seven
map it's nurse seven man and it's
already been approved by the EMA the
Europeans medicine
Council so uh and it's under review by
the FDA so it should also
be reviewed and decided on by next
winter season and
now these this antibody is derived from
one of the antibodies we use to
do the crystallization of the prefusion
if and it is uh given to infants at the
time of birth and it's it's been tested
in full-term infants and one of the
things we know about RSV is that if Anna
if you can give an antibody that
neutralizes the virus
early in life it can be done safely and
effectively because there's a antibody
called palavizamab that's been used
since the late 90s
it's been restricted very strictly to
very young infants 29 weeks gestation or
less but this new antibody that's also
been modified with long Half-Life
mutation
it is uh being given to full-term
infants so it would be available for all
babies born
uh and and has been shown to be highly
effective at least through 150 days
very exciting okay so a second
monoclonal antibody available for for a
wider group of infants not just
premature infants
at um I want to move to a question from
our audience this this is on the topic
of safety but you've addressed Barney
already in response to several questions
and this viewer is asking what is the
correlation between myocarditis and RSV
vaccines role and what is RSV vaccine's
role in recent cases and what are safety
regulations that have been used in in
the context of measuring these
incidences of myocarditis I think I have
that's the question
okay well uh this person's asking about
myocarditis as far as I know
there hasn't been any uh events of
myocarditis with any of the RSV vaccines
or antibodies tested today
maybe okay so maybe they're thinking
about covid-19 and if if the person who
posed that question wants to follow up
and ask and clarify
um please feel free if there's part of
your question that I've missed it looks
like we have another question coming in
on the chat
um
so I will wait for that one
okay
um can you talk a little bit about how
um
RSV and covid differ in severity for
people of different age groups it's kind
of a broad question of comparing the two
well they're they're different types of
viruses but in some ways they share
features so they're both envelope
viruses they're both RNA viruses they
both have class one Fusion proteins but
a big difference with RSV is that
everybody on Earth has been infected
with RSV and they get repeatedly
infected throughout life and so the
severe times for disease are very early
in life before six months of age peaking
at around two months of age
and then very late in life when you've
become frail or you have an immune or
compromised state or
different conditions that could make the
virus worse
Verona virus the new coronavirus one
associated with cobot 19
came to the human population for the
first time and there was no pre-existing
immunity no one had ever been infected
with this virus before and so
we are now gradually coming out of the
pandemic this virus is becoming an
endemic virus and it will settle into
what I think will be a seasonal pattern
it will be coming back around probably
most winter seasons and we'll have to
see what kind of disease pattern it
eventually assumes it doesn't appear to
cause severe disease in very young
infants like RSV but it will probably
always have some severe disease in the
very old frail
immunocompromised people
in for you Greg viewers are wondering if
you could talk a little bit about how
people have reacted to your book maybe
surprising responses they've had about
efforts to make the vaccines which would
also be relevant for RSV
well one of the themes is that those who
develop these vaccines are not who you
would have expected you would have
expected it to be a big Pharma right and
I frankly came into my project a little
bit skeptical of researchers I'm big
Pharma we've written enough stories at
the Wall Street Journal and elsewhere
about pricing and other kind of issues
and I gained a whole new respect and I
came at this again as a skeptical kind
of journalist but the researchers uh
both on this panel and elsewhere are
dedicated they're Republicans they're
Democrats they're not political and
frankly they're trying to help us all
and in this environment we're in an
environment where
um for whatever reason everything's
politicized it's sad it's not kind of
play down the middle one night talk to
these people and they've dedicated their
lives to This research and they have
this resilience and there is persistence
which is admirable and frankly we all
talk about technological innovation
coming out of Silicon Valley everything
Silicon Valley and today's AI but these
researchers they are at the heart of
technological innovation that um is
admirable and I think we can learn from
whether we're in this industry or not
and we should be grateful as well I mean
the reason why we're out and about and
doing what we are nowadays is to vaccine
researchers like Barney and Jason and
others so I'm not here to defend them
I'm here to promote them in any way and
I came into this project my book project
um a little bit skeptical and you talk
about reactions yeah a lot of people
have been surprised about who it was and
what kinds of people we're responsible
for these vaccines and they were
surprised that it wasn't you know myrrh
GSK in the vaccine Giants so um there's
a lot of dedication in this industry and
I I gained a newfound respect for for
the researchers
yeah humanizing the story of the work
emphasizing the gratitude
for now we have a question that relates
to the fact that again two of the
vaccines are being reviewed by advisory
committees to the FDA this week
someone's asking about concerns they'd
seen about
um very the very small number of cases
of again Barre Syndrome a neurological
syndrome how how worried should we be
about that I think they reported one
case for one of the vaccines for the
elderly and perhaps two for the other so
very small number but we did did hear
those results Barney I think this is for
you
foreign
well this is what I meant about safety
first and uh the first thing every group
developing a vaccine does is is make
sure the trial is large enough to assess
safety even things that happen uh rarely
and so
there were a couple of what I would
classify as demyelinating type syndromes
that either central nervous system or
peripheral nervous system that were
associated or closely occurred close to
the vaccine and so this is the kind of
thing that is such a rare event it's
hard to know how to judge that relative
to how many people the vaccine is
helping
and it's often the kind of thing that
you continue to study what's called
post-marketing so once the vaccine is
into millions of people
you can get a better sense and this
would be done in real time and so if
there were events that were concerning
both the manufacturers and the FDA
and the CDC would all have access to
that real-time data and be able to stop
if there was something that looked
concerning
thanks Barney that's really helpful to
know how the process would go
everyone we are we are nearly at times
oh I want to end with a question for
everybody and um I think I'll start with
with you Jason what what lessons do you
want viewers to take from the the
history the story that you've told today
even in short form about the history of
of developing RSV vaccines
I think maybe one thing that's not
appreciated is just that the the work
takes hundreds or thousands of people
over decades
um so you know if you're seeing a few of
us we've mentioned a few names but it's
really uh just a tremendous number of
people
dating back to when the virus was first
discovered in the mid 1950s it's a lot
of failure science takes time it's
self-correcting uh you know
hopefully we ultimately get there and
can one day produce effective vaccines
so I think it's exciting for for the
field to finally have efficacious
vaccines being evaluated for approval
now
thanks Jason and for everything you're
doing in your lab man how about you what
lessons should we take from this the
story
yeah I think I have one point the uh
scientific collaboration is important
and improve our research we collaborated
with the Minnesota Jazz group find the
monochonal antibody prefusion antibody
successfully we will find different
research background with special
expertise we will learn each other
sharing the knowledge expertise and
technology which speed up and work and
improve the efficiency and creativity of
the project
and collaboration benefits to all of us
yeah you use the word creativity
thinking about collaboration informing
creativity it's so exciting we need more
of it thank you man and Greg how about
you the lessons we should take with us
today
well I heard the word collaboration and
that's huge both in terms of uh this
vaccine and the research and covet as
well but I also I think it's important
for all of us to um not count out the
dreamers so many of the people behind
the RSP uh breakthroughs and and also
covet vaccine were kind of dismissed
um their efforts were maybe people were
skeptical about them and there's
something they said for giving dreamers
a chance and allowing them persistence
to finally pay off I've become a little
more patient with those who have these
big crazy kind of dreams and and we're
trying to help people and try to say
save lives so I I applaud those those
dreamers and in the scientific community
thanks Greg I would love to share that
message with my children as they're
thinking about dreaming in science and
other fields uh how about you Barney
what lessons should we take from your
long work in this space
well first I just want to highlight the
importance of basic science research and
the importance of supporting basic
research because if if anything this
story is a great story
exemplifying how basic research on how
the protein Works what it looks like
uh all with an eye toward human disease
at some point but really focused on
basic mechanisms basic biology this is
the the basis for how we got to this
point and then the the concept that we
learned in RSV was applied to the
coronavirus problem and and so basic
science Builds on itself and if I could
be allowed to just say one more thing
that uh we're now we're now looking into
a future where
we have technologies that can be
effective and we know how to use them we
know how to see things that we didn't
used to be able to see that had changed
everything
and
we need to Now look for uh the ways
we're going to use that technology and
deploy that technology and share that
technology because
viruses don't have borders and we this
this these vaccines need to be
accessible to all people
and if we're going to take this
technology forward especially for
pandemic preparedness and other disease
Concepts
it needs to be something that is uh
being worked on on in a global way and
so all there's several other things we
could say but I'll stop there yeah yeah
um well the importance of basic research
is certainly something aaas in science
are very much behind and creativity and
collaboration communication the dreamers
working in these spaces will help us
prepare for the next pandemic thankfully
hopefully that's a great message on
which to end we didn't get to all the
questions today but thank you for
everyone who watched and thank you again
to our speakers I hope you all have an
excellent rest of the week and we can
look forward to seeing the results from
the advisory committee as they weigh in
on that second RSV vaccine any moment
now
thanks again everyone have a great
afternoon okay thank you
see you off